I've been care driver in Chicago around
12 years I do the job like here 12 hours
a day every day I walk because I have
four kids I have to support my kids and
my family and all the time I thank this
country because they bring me as refuges
to this country every day and bless
first my family and I say to my family
god bless america
[Music]
[Music]
are you today my friend thank God no
complaint my friend I never complain
never complained never I need to hear
that all the time customer they asked me
for your phone I told them if you know
what I am for my giving 3y I'm gonna
give you a clue look like a cash card
you know my hand I'm gonna give you my
name my culture my religion my language
this is my name Estefan be chelita okay
that's my name got it
our culture we used to control the world
our culture now doesn't exist religion
we are the first Christian language we
speak Aramaic now this is for the clue
you guess what I am from I'll give you
free wife come on
yes okay it's gonna be a big fair how
many guesses do I get three strike three
strike you're out
this is not good okay let me see your
name again it's Stefan Stefan the
Spanish no no no no no strategy it
doesn't count as yes macedonian you are
you are too close but too far the Moors
the Spanish Moors strike one
strike one yes it's it one fifty fifty
are you in a call a friend
no I'm gonna figure it out okay go ahead
you're killing me don't kick me out no
no don't no I need a ride that's what I
forgot my kid like a beggar give up yes
I give up
my name Estefan Vidal shalida I am from
Iraq I born in Basra south of Iraq when
I was a teenager back home I was a
neighborhood tough guy my cousin his
name is area you know he was champion of
Iraq and boxing he asked me you think
you are tough
I say why he said put the gloves and let
me see if you are tough I was sparked
with him I was giving him a hard time
they say hey you are good we say I'm
gonna introduce you to the Department of
the sport Navy sport when I turned 18 I
was professional boxer and professional
soccer goalkeeper in the first team in
Iraq I used to skip school gosh go to
the gym you know watch him fight it was
a young tall skinny handsome ah
goalkeeper boxer and what do you know
him when you somebody say something oh
you you Steve his nephew oh yeah we know
his champion used to you know make you
feel good you know especially when
somebody related to you and you see
you've knocked out people and movie like
it's my uncle good
we were going me and my uncle youngest
uncle and him he had a fight so we all
preparing it on he's like everybody he
was the favor anyone like this first
round like 1050 second poof and he went
down and we were like oh get out get up
[Music]
man my uncle got up his eyes was like
tipped off
he was just bleeding from his nose after
that for three round he beat him up so
much the whole stadium was screaming for
soups hails artists as we look observe
and look sale the guy is named as hell
we become punching bag
[Music]
I was the light heavyweight champion of
Iraq from 68 to 76 and all the media
every time all the media boxing they
picked my name to represent Iraqi
national team they sent me to the
training camp 5-time 5-time they sent me
home I don't know why some friends they
told me maybe because you are Christian
or maybe you are not in the bath party
they took my father for eight months and
my father with the bath boy they took
him for eight months they put him in
this they tortured him and then after
that really same we sorry
and my father quit the bath party he
gathered all the guys in a family and
say this is not our country this is
never gonna be ours uncle gathered his
staff my father got him the ticket and
they say you don't say um we take an off
say I'm going on vacation government of
Iraq if they know I'm gonna leave and
not come back they put me in jail my
family they told me Estefan mr. Liang we
want you to be jumpy on it want you to
be something in your life leave Iraq
I left Iraq 1976 I run away from Iraq to
Greece I left behind for brother and for
sister my mother and my father but I was
trying to be like any professional boxer
any champion they don't look behind just
look forward
when I was in Greece
I was practice with the team
Panathinaikos club they told me hey we
need you to come with us every day to
practice with us the trainer of the
national team he told me Estefan if you
want we can give you the opportunity to
represent Greek national team I told
them I can represent your country I was
too tired to make mentally and
physically because mentally I left my
family home and I run away from my
country and physically as I was working
12 hours 10 hours a day in the factory I
was working under the table just to
survive
[Music]
at that time when I was working I met
beautiful girl I first met him I was so
nervous I don't want to talk to him she
gave me like a angry face then he talked
to my friends go talk to Anna hi I love
her you know my friend
Greek lady she's all his nice guy he's a
handsome guy why you don't want to talk
to him he said no I don't want to talk
to him I want to go to America with my
brother he was here I don't want to get
married here I don't want to engage here
and she's told me you're not going to
find a guy in America like Stefan then I
changed my mind
I talked to him I asked her where you
from she told me I'm from Iraq oh I told
her I am from Iraq too
she say I'm from the north I told her
I'm from the south she told me you're
gonna stay in Greece I say no I'm
applying for political refugees he
half-cousin install eeeh they make I
think they make his paper but he wasn't
loving he don't want to go to Australia
I told her you go to Mecca I'm gonna
follow you if you go to make a cup
tomato
you
[Music]
we got married then he start boxing here
I met early Terrell his champion of the
world
and they're literally give me certified
and I have five win to lose his face was
swelling
you know bruising in steep I said you
have to stop you have to stop my son
born back in eighty I stopped
[Music]
I think the fact that he he comes home
like a 14-hour day I mean just happy
happy to see us happy to be home happy
to be alive happy to have a job from
what I hear he's always been a happy a
happy chip out happy camper
yeah I think he's always been like that
I think that's what keeps us going him
being so positive because he's had such
a hard a difficult life I think he
overlooks the little things that would
bother anybody he just thinks about his
family wanting to see them and and that
just brings him joy his job brings him
joy talking to so many people about his
life brings enjoy the customer I told
them you know what I have four million
dollars oh they told me how you have
four million dollars I told him listen
to this I have four kids born dinner
that's my fortune
that's my four million dollars you never
know what was gonna be and that's nice
my kids my parents haven't seen their
parents and 30-some years so my mom
always told us when we were kids like
you're my mom
you're my dad or the way I loved my mom
and dad that's how much I love you
I I look the picture so you know I come
from the big family we were six sister
and one brother was big family was nice
life you know all together going to
airplane to leave Iraq I see my sister
and that's it was last time in my life I
didn't see her then I went to Greece
then after the Odyssey I didn't see my
family we talked each other but I didn't
see my family I miss everybody I miss my
sister I miss my mom I miss my dad I
miss all of them but I can't do nothing
my parents died I don't seen him his
parents died he didn't see I can I can
go to see the the funeral because I'll
scare everybody other than me they put
me in jail all they'd kill me yeah
my sister she went to my village only
rock
no no houses no nothing they bombed
Church I was screaming crying everybody
in church this sometimes time nobody can
do that that's not what the world what
they say yeah they say we used to have
sat down one sundown now we have 40
Sodra tweeny just peace in that country
everywhere
north-south-east-west everywhere
[Music]
[Music]
I didn't think I was going to grease and
find somebody in love and engage I'd
never think about that I say this I only
get out from the rock something cable
eyes was gift for both of us
yes that's gift yeah for both of us
[Music]
you
sometimes I think what if my dad never
took that step to change his flight
ticket and be like coming with you
sweetheart and come with you honey
[Music]
if I didn't have my dad like I wouldn't
know what to do but thinking of like
having a different father than who I
have milk would be devastating I think
it would be heartbreaking
[Music]
my husband he was champion and I won
raised my kids gentlemen like my husband
well gentlemen he was champion I want my
kids be just like him
we know each other from almost 36 years
right yeah 37 - oh yeah we got we still
in love right oh yeah I love him I love
you more than my life I love you too
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]